hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well in
plato's republic book too
he's dealing with problems that these
two brothers glaucon and adam mantis are
are raising that follow up on
thrasymachus's
sort of might makes right you know very
radical attack on traditional notions of
right
wrong or of justice and
one of the arguments that glaucon makes
very early on
hinges on this this important
distinction between different kinds of
goods
and we want to figure out with these
different kinds of goods
what kind of good is justice so
let's actually look at the distinction
that he makes now these terms intrinsic
and instrumental
are not terms that glaucon himself is
using or plato is using in this
there are ways of understanding it that
i think
help you out as you're making sense out
of it
and glaucon asked socrates
do you think there's there's or do you
agree that there's this kind of good
this kind of good this kind of good
so one kind of good he talks about as
being the type of good under which
fall these these different examples of
them we would say that they're laborious
and painful yet beneficial
and yet further for their own sake we
would not accept them
we're not desiring them for their own
reason because we love them or anything
like that
we like them we want them we aim after
them
because they provide rewards and other
benefits
so that's what it means for something to
be a purely instrumental good
you don't desire it for its own sake you
want it for something else
and he gives you some examples um
you know they're productive well they're
good exercise now some people come to
like exercise
but for most of us exercise is kind of a
pain you have to make time for it
it's you know laborious you sweat a lot
you know
you could run through the whole list
right
medicine now back in his time they
didn't have you know
cherry medicine and bubble gum tasting
medicine all that sort of stuff
we we've managed to make medicines a lot
more palatable but there's still a lot
of types of remedies which
you know they're no fun um
there are people who abuse you know say
painkillers and things like that but
there's i don't think there's a lot of
people who say
abuse antibiotics for their own sake who
say
man i can't get enough doxycycline
because that stuff makes you
you know nauseous and feel bad
but why do you take it well because it's
bringing about some other good for you
it's making you
feel better in the case of an antibiotic
it's killing some
other agent which is messing up your
body money making
it's fun to make money but money by
itself is a merely instrumental good
and the kinds of activities that are
done to make money
if they're being done primarily to make
money
are really not an awful lot of fun you
know why do people
go to work sometimes they actually like
their job in that case it's something
else that's going on but a lot of people
go to work because
they got to make money because money
provides all the other things that they
do want to have
so these are purely instrumental goods
we can come up with all sorts of other
examples of purely instrumental goods if
we want to
over at the other extreme are the kinds
of goods
that glaucon says kind of good which we
would
choose to possess not from desire for
its after effects but welcoming it for
its own sake
what are the examples that he gives of
that um
joy and such pleasures as are harmless
and nothing results from them afterwards
and again we could probably think of a
lot of other things that we desire for
their own sake not because we're
actually going to get something else
out of it nothing else is going to be
produced by it
i i don't think that we have to if we're
making this distinction
i don't think we have to like insist too
much that they can't be productive of
any other goods
you know think for example of
enjoying an activity together with
somebody else
now that could be productive of other
goods right because
that person might turn out to be a good
business contact
and then it produced another good or
maybe you become friends with them and
the friendship blossoms
or you end up in a romantic relationship
with them you realize that you actually
are attracted to each other it's not
being done
if it's an intrinsic good it's not being
done or enjoyed just
for the sake of other goods other goods
could result from it but
they don't usually result from it or
necessarily result from it
if that would be the case that would be
in this third category this middle
category
which glaucon talks about
as being um
goods that we love both for its own sake
and for its consequences
uh one of the examples that he gives of
this understanding or mental
faculties no you know you might look at
your education
or the use of your mind as a purely
instrumental good
but one of the things that you see in
plato very clearly and a lot of other
philosophers
is a recognition that for those who
actually
do develop their intellects it becomes
pleasurable
it becomes enjoyable it becomes
satisfying
to think about things to work out
puzzles to you know
figure things out and so
understanding is something that's useful
for other things
i mean if you master a
intellectual or a practical skill
you can do other things right you can
produce something
but if you master it you probably also
like it too
you probably also get something out of
it you get a kick out of it you
you find some fun you find some
challenge in it
maybe even actually you know you connect
up with other people who like the same
sort of thing and then it kind of
augments it
well that means that it's an
instrumental good because it can produce
some things for you
that are not the same thing as the
understanding but it's also an intrinsic
good
something that's valuable for its own
sake site
you might say well why is that the case
well
site is pretty useful for getting around
right so you don't bump into things so
it is an instrumental good
but it's also valuable for its own sake
because
you like to look at things you don't
just want to avoid bumping into the
table
you actually like to look at that thing
over there watch
tv or you know pick whatever else you
like to look at
that means that it has an intrinsic good
or intrinsic value rather that makes it
good health
um being healthy is something that by
itself is a good
and it's also you might say a
prerequisite to
a lot of other goods if you're not
healthy it's hard to enjoy
a lot of the finer things in life as a
matter of fact some people might get
themselves healthy
just so that they can enjoy other things
i know i you know i'm a bad one in this
respect
my main interest in being healthy
is so that i get to live longer and i
get to spend more time with the people
who i like and get to read more books
and get to do more
philosophical discussion and those sorts
of things you know i'm not actually
valuing health so much for its own sake
i'm seeing it more as a
instrumental good but if i saw it
rightly i would say that being healthy
is a good thing in and of itself it's an
intrinsic good
so we've got this distinction between
these three different kinds of good
and it's interesting in in plato
at least with glaucon
is it the case that you go from here
over to here in a continuum and you go
from you know the lesser good
all the way up to the higher good or
highest good
well
not exactly the way glaucon is framing
it
this is the lesser good it's purely
instrumental you're not you wouldn't
go after it if you had some other way of
getting it
what it is that you want if you had
another way of getting health you
wouldn't need medicine right
if you had another way of getting the
the goods that you want you wouldn't
engage in money making
if you didn't have another way of making
yourself have a the kind of body that
you want you probably wouldn't engage in
exercise
you could think about that with
knowledge too if the knowledge could be
poured directly into your head maybe you
wouldn't spend a lot of time reading
books and thinking about
philosophers so that's a lesser type of
good
this is also at least in in this
discussion
it's it's a higher type of good but it's
not as high of a type of good as this
and i think the
basic idea behind it is this is a good
that's productive
of other goods so that you have a larger
quantity of good total
this is stuff that's worth pursuing for
its own sake worth having for its own
sake
this is worth having for its own sake
but there is also the gravy
of some other good coming along with it
so
here's what glaucon asks socrates then
he says
in which of these classes do you place
justice
and socrates says in my opinion it
belongs in the fairest class that which
a man who is to be happy must
love both for its own sake and for the
results so socrates is saying justice
fits in here
is that how everybody sees it glauken
says yet the multitude
don't think so but that it belongs to
the toilsome
class of things that must be practiced
for the sake of rewards and repute
due to opinion but that in itself is to
be shown as an affliction so
justice being a just person doing the
right thing
cultivating this this kind of
reliability within your personality or
character or soul
where other people can say yeah that
guy's not going to screw me over that
guy's not going to lie to me
that guy is not going to try to seduce
my wife or her spouse
that guy is not going to sneak up on me
in the middle of the night and hit me
over the head
take everything i've got
he's saying glaucon is saying most
people see
justice that disposition within the
person following the rules
doing the right thing is something like
medicine
it's bitter you don't want to have it
but you realize that you're better off
with it than without it it's not
something that you see as actually
you know enjoyable desirable
lovable for it for its own sake
um and this is what thrasymachus has
been saying as well
so
glaucon is is asking socrates to provide
some way of
justifying not only to the you know
the philosopher but to the average
person
or at least to the average educated
person why it is that justice
ought to be seen as falling in here
rather than as falling in here and
that's a really
important distinction to make
there's a big separation between
these sorts of things isn't there
it's a matter of priorities so
the the question that that's being
explored here
is how should we order things how should
we
see justice i'm going to explain a few
things that aren't in the text but are
sort of implicit there if something is
merely an instrumental good
that means that it's totally replaceable
so long as you could find something else
that would give you the same result
the same outcome the same
good thing that you're aiming at you
could get rid of it
if you could actually get that good
thing that it produces
by itself without having to do the
instrumental good
you could brush off that instrumental
good because remember instrumental goods
are not things that we actually desire
for the sake
of themselves and for other things
they're things that we don't really like
they're only a good
because they they give us something else
so if justice is that sort of thing
then and if justice is you know some
understood as like
a disposition within the soul
if we could find something else that
would act like that we could get rid of
justice we wouldn't need it
it would be no longer instrumental we'd
have a better instrument
on the other hand if it's over here then
it's something
that is actually worthwhile
if that's the case if justice falls over
here even if it were to fall over here
being an intrinsic good
that would mean that it would be
something that
we would want to have even if we weren't
getting something out of it
or we would want to have even if it
turns out that it
doesn't in some cases act instrumentally
and provide us with the other things
that we want you know i mean what what
can justice provide us with
well other people like us they don't
throw us in prison
they treat us well in return those are
all
things that justice leads to
instrumentally
the question is do we ought we
you know would a right-handed person see
justice as something that's worthwhile
for its own count even if it doesn't pay
off for you
so what glaucon tells them
is he says what i desire to hear
it what i desire is to hear what each
one of them that is justice and
injustice is and what potency and effect
each has in and of itself dwelling in
the soul what what does it do to the
person who has justice
or who has injustice to dismiss the
rewards and consequences so he's saying
to socrates
look a lot of people are after justice
and they say it's a good thing
because it pays off for for them to have
it or for other people to have it
you know because then they're not
stealing or robbing or cheating them
um i want to put that stuff aside and i
want to hear you tell me
why having justice
in your soul in your personality in the
structure of your character who you are
would actually be a good thing for you
and not
just something that you have for the
sake of other goods
that's what's going on in this this
passage
you